SETH LADD: Welcome everyone
to Episode 11.
And today, we are going to talk
to engineers from the
dart2js team.
And so stick around, and you
could learn how we get Dart
code to run across
modern browsers.
[INTRO MUSIC]
JJ BEHRENS: I'm JJ Behrens.
This is Seth Ladd.
SETH LADD: Hello.
First, the news.
This all comes thanks to Chris
Buckett's dartwatch blog.
So thank you for collecting
all the news.
First off, Mike Eberhart has
created Dart Squid, his UI SVG
components.
Now, have you worked with SVG?
JJ BEHRENS: No, actually
I haven't.
For some reason, I've never
gotten a chance do that.
SETH LADD: I think it's
underappreciated technology.
And I look forward to more
deployments of SVG, and
especially with Dart.
So check out Mike's library.
JJ BEHRENS: The thing I don't
like about SVG is I'm not a
very attractive guy.
And so what I'd like is taking
a picture of myself as a GIF,
and then blowing it up,
I'm kind of fuzzy.
But in SVG, it's like--
SETH LADD: It is vector
graphics.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
It's like you could
see everything.
There's no hiding
behind the fuzz.
SETH LADD: Simon Pai,
from the Dart
framework builders Rikulo--
and you can remember them from
a previous episode--
has blogged about a rotatable
map prototype.
So it's really cool
to see another UI
framework built in Dart.
And these guys are friends
of the project.
And it's fun to track
their project.
Florian Loitsch, one of the
members of the dart2js team--
JJ BEHRENS: We'll hear
for him in a minute.
SETH LADD: Yes, will be speaking
on JavaScript as a
compilation target
at JSConf EU.
Now, this is really cool.
It's a heavy JavaScript
conference.
But we're going to talk
about how we get Dart
to JavaScript there.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, that turns out
to be a lot more complex
than I thought it would be.
SETH LADD: And with the Pub, the
package manager for Dart,
getting released very
soon-- in fact
it's in the SDK today--
the server components are
coming online shortly.
And you see more documentation
posted about how to create a
package, what does the
versioning system look like,
and how to declare your
dependencies.
In preparation, the Dart
M1 language changes.
Now this is cool.
The editor will help you quick
fix or clean-up your--
it sounds weird, but
legacy dart code.
That is the code before the
M1 line in the sand of the
release, if you will.
And so it will help you update
the syntax for things like the
try catch blocks, interfaces
to classes, and more.
And so Definitely
try this out.
And as more implementations of
the new language features come
online, the new editor clean-ups
will get even more
and more useful.
JJ BEHRENS: Dude, this
is frickin' magical.
For a long time, I was super
jealous over Go, because Go
had this nice thing where it
could automatically upgrade
your code to new APIs.
But now we have it directly
in the editor.
I'm super psyched about this.
SETH LADD: Yeah, this
is awesome.
So try out that feature and
let us know how it works.
So John Evans, one of the early
adopters of Dart and the
author of the Buckshot UI
framework, has been blogging
about his experience using
the Mirrors API.
Now, mirrors are awesome because
it's our way to do
reflection, things like tell
me more about the class I'm
operating with, and I think in
the future, do things like
construct a class on the fly.
Finally, for more news, we
have a 83% more awesome
api.dartlang.org site now,
with a "find as you type"
search feature.
Now, have you tried this?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, briefly.
But I'm really wondering,
how'd you
come up with the 83%?
SETH LADD: It's very
complicated.
We had to use 6,000 cores in
Compute Engine, wrote it all
with Dart, but it
is verifiable.
And it's really nice because we
have a lot of classes and
interfaces that use, for
instance, the word "element".
And sometimes you want to just
find the superclass element.
Now you go right up to the
search box type "element," and
it comes up in a nice
ranking order.
And so much easier now to browse
around if you just want
to know what does
our API provide.
So definitely try that out.
JJ BEHRENS: It's funny, if
you're a language guy like I
am, you kind of spend
all your time
thinking about the language.
But actually, a lot of those
other things actually really
help out your productivity.
Because spending a lot of that
time searching through docs
instead of having something that
immediately takes to what
you want could really increase
your productivity.
So I'm excited about that.
SETH LADD: Yeah, yeah.
Great.
Well, that's what we
have for the news.
So now let's invite
our guests.
JJ BEHRENS: Wait, hang on.
I'm going to do it.
You ready?
SETH LADD: One, two, three.
[SNAPS FINGERS]
SETH LADD: Ta-dah!
JJ BEHRENS: Hey, welcome
to the show, guys.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Thanks.
SETH LADD: How was that?
Your first magical
teleportation.
KASPER LUND: Not
the first, no.
SETH LADD: No, not
the first, right.
PETER VAN DER AHE:
It's my first.
It's more easier than
I expected.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
So can you say something
cool in Danish?
KASPER LUND: [SPEAKING DANISH].
JJ BEHRENS: I can't tell
if that's cool or not.
KASPER LUND: [SPEAKING DANISH].
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, well,
that's obvious.
SETH LADD: Bring in some good
YouTube comments from that.
So most importantly, how
do you pronounce
[SPEAKING DANISH]?
PETER VAN DER AHE:
[SPEAKING DANISH].
SETH LADD: [SPEAKING DANISH].
KASPER LUND: That was
pretty close.
JJ BEHRENS: You guys want
to introduce yourselves?
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Yes,
I'm Florian Loitsch.
And, I've been working on Dart
since the beginning.
My background is basically
scheme and compilers.
I wrote scheme to JavaScript
compiler.
And then I wrote JavaScript
to scheme compiler.
And then I joined the V8 team.
And then eventually, I
transitioned to Dart.
And now I'm working on a Dart
to JavaScript compiler.
So JavaScripts--
SETH LADD: It always comes
back to JavaScript.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: --and Darts,
dynamic languages, scheme.
That's my background.
JJ BEHRENS: Awesome.
JJ BEHRENS: And I'm
Kasper Lund.
I worked on Dart since
the beginning, too.
Now, I'm working on dart2js,
compiling Dart to efficient
JavaScript code.
Before that, I spent some years
on optimizing JavaScript
in Chrome and the V8 engines.
I had a lot of work
in trying to make
JavaScript run really quickly.
So now it's nice to be able to
make good use of that by
compiling to it as a
target language.
PETER VON DER AHE: My name
is Peter von der Ahe.
And I work on dart2js.
I mostly focus on the front end,
that is, passing symbol
resolution and stuff like
that-- type checking,
inferring types, perhaps.
And then before joining Google,
I had worked on Java
Caesar, the compiler.
And I've also worked on Gilad
Bracha's Newspeak project.
JJ BEHRENS: Wow.
SETH LADD: We should do a shout
out to the rest of the
dart2js team, who we only have
this big of a couch, but we
have a really awesome team.
We want to thank everyone
for all their work.
And I should probably say, we
have an external contributor
working on dart2js.
Is that right?
KASPER LUND: That is true.
SETH LADD: It's our first
installed contributor.
PETER VON DER AHE: After
submitting a few CLs on his
behalf, we asked him if he
wanted to be a full-scale
committer on the project.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
pretty amazing.
KASPER LUND: That's nice.
More resources.
JJ BEHRENS: I also think that
really points out the open
source nature of Dart.
SETH LADD: So I'm really
interested in the design of
the language and how it's been
impacted by what has always
been a core belief of ours
that it has to compile to
fast, sane, logical
JavaScript.
Can we talk a little bit about
how that's impacted?
KASPER LUND: Yeah, from the
get-go, we knew that being
able to run on any browser was
really important for Dart to
be interesting to people that
wanted to develop big, large
web apps for the real world.
So we looked at the constraints
imposed by using
JavaScript as a target
language.
And some of the things that we
probably wanted to try out in
the language were really hard
to do when compiled to
JavaScript.
A few of them are things like
non-local returns, where you
can return from an
inner function.
And you actually end up
returning, not from the
function itself, but from the
enclosing functions instead,
which is a really
cool feature.
It's just hard to implement in
JavaScript efficiently because
it ends up being something with
their own exceptions.
So that's something we dropped
and said let's
not do that for now.
It's too complicated to
make that efficient.
So let's keep it closer to what
you can do in JavaScript.
There are a few other things
that we also decided not to
push too hard on.
On the syntax front, we tried
to stay reasonably true to
JavaScript so it would
look familiar,
feel familiar to people.
I think that's very important
for adoption.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: I think in
Java, when we had the choice
when we weren't sure and there
were several valid choices, we
picked the one from JavaScript
just to make it comfortable
and to make it familiar to
JavaScript developers.
KASPER LUND: You could say that
the async programming
style that we use in Dart
is also inherited from
JavaScript.
We're not ruling out allowing
users to tell us to trust the
type of notations if they
really need that for
deployment.
It's just putting that in too
early will essentially remove
all pressure from us to deliver
something that's
really, really nice without
those slightly hacky
optimizations, right?
So we like to have that pressure
put on us to deliver
something that's really fast
without unsafe optimizations.
SETH LADD: I think it's
also a workflow issue.
The way we envision Dart being
deployed a lot is it's a very
scalable language.
So you can start with just some
functions and a small
prototype, and you
don't really have
types in play here.
And we want people to
start that way.
And so we don't want people to
necessarily type everything at
the very beginning.
Of course, you can if you'd
like, but you should have that
option to scale up to very type
systems starting from a
very small R&D project,
if you will.
JJ BEHRENS: Definitely.
SETH LADD: Before we take the
questions, I want to actually
dive in a little bit
to what happens in
dart2js, for instance.
So I think this is a good point
for our viewers, who
might come from, say, a
CoffeeScript background, or
who had this idea that, OK, I
can compile it in one language
or convert one language
to another.
But in dart2js, I think we have
different semantics and
that governs non-straightforward
way.
JJ BEHRENS: It's not a syntax
transformation.
SETH LADD: That's what
I'm trying to say.
Thank you.
JJ BEHRENS: It's even a semantic
transformation.
SETH LADD: Yeah, so can
you talk about that?
For instance, what happens when
I compile and add "int a
comma int b" into JavaScript?
KASPER LUND: So Peter was sort
of saying that the biggest
problem is really that you
cannot just compile a Dart
plus to a JavaScript plus.
And that's exactly right.
And so for method calls, like
calling a "foo" a "bar" on
some objects, it's sort of a
pretty direct translation.
We have some slightly more
advanced ways of passing
arguments, which needs
to be dealt with.
But other than that, we're just
using JavaScript function
calls to implement Dart function
calls essentially.
But on the primitive values
where we use JavaScript
numbers and stuff, it's a
bit more complicated.
Because in Dart, you can
provide a user-defined
implementation of an operator
like plus, and it needs to
work in the right way.
Whereas in JavaScript, there is
really no way of defining a
user-defined plus operator.
You can just use the one
that's built in.
And if your optics have the
right value-off method, they
might participate in this kind
of built-in plus operation.
So Dart is more flexible
there than JavaScript.
But it also means that there's
sort of a semantic gap between
Dart plus and JavaScript plus.
In itself, it's pretty easy
to implement Dart plus.
It's just very slow if you
compile to JavaScript and just
essentially turn a plus
into a method call.
So we go through I would say
great lengths to try to figure
out when it's safe to compile
a Dart plus into
a JavaScript plus.
And it's only safe under
certain assumptions.
It's only safe when you
know you're operating
on JavaScript numbers.
Otherwise, you're not getting
the right semantics.
For instance, if you end up
operating on JavaScript
strings instead, you'll get
string concatenation out of
it, because that's what
JavaScript does for plus, and
that's not the Dart way.
So that's one of the big
challenges we have is just
pushing enough type information
around the system
to know when we can safely
translate a plus to a plus.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Then we
also have speculative
optimizations.
So, in particular, for arrays
or array accesses, we don't
want to go through helper
methods to do that.
So what we do is if we see that
this might be a loop that
works with arrays,
we do the check.
If it's a JavaScript array
before the loop, we check if
the index is an integer.
And usually the index is just
incremented to the loop.
So once we know it's
an integer, it
will stay an integer.
So we do that before the loop.
And in the loop we have a
nice efficient access.
And in case it's not an array
or it's not an integer, we
have a bailout method.
So we jump to another method,
and there we do the slow
accesses where we go through
helper methods to make sure
that if the array
is actually--
if the indexed object is
actually not on array, then we
go through the methods of it and
make sure that everything
works as expected.
KASPER LUND: And again, that's
because indexing into lists
and collections in Dart is a
user-definable operator.
So you can write your own
collection type that allows
you to index into it.
That's not possible
in something
like JavaScript either.
So we have to make use of the
JavaScript primitive indexing
operation when we can, when we
know it's safe, or when we can
generate essentially a two-code
pass where it's safe
in one and maybe faster.
Or we just do this bailout
version that will do the right
thing, but be slower.
So if you ever look at the
generated JavaScript, the
output from the dart2js compiler
and find these
slightly weird bailout methods,
that's the reason.
It's because we're doing
speculative optimizations
where we're not guaranteed
at compile time
that this will hold.
So we have to generate two
versions, essentially.
One thing that many people
probably don't know is that,
at least on certain JavaScript
VMs, at least the one's I'm
intimately familiar with which
is mostly V8, there's actually
a cost associated with passing
the wrong number of arguments.
Passing too few is costly.
Passing too many
is costly, too.
It's not cost in the sense
that your program will be
super, super slow if
you get it wrong.
But just to make essentially the
sequences and instructions
you have to execute to call
something and return efficient
in the common case, it's heavily
optimized for the case
where you pass exactly the right
number of arguments.
So there's a good reason to
do that if you care about
performance, especially for the
hot loops in your code.
JJ BEHRENS: "Will dart2js be
able to output compressed
minified JavaScript like the
Google Closure compiler in
advanced mode?
If it can compress properties,
it also has to create a
property mapping text file
that could be used in web
services JavaScript
serializers." Well, we get the
first half of this question
a lot, don't we, Seth?
SETH LADD: We do.
And you could just see a patch
that landed very recently--
dash, dash, minify.
Tell us what happens when
you use that new
command-line argument?
KASPER LUND: So I can take
responsibility for the
command-line argument.
And Florian can take
responsibility for what
happens when you use it.
[LAUGHTER]
KASPER LUND: The Minify option
is the answer to this
question, essentially.
Yes, we will be providing a
way of outputting minified
compressed JavaScript output.
And we will make good use of
the fact that we understand
the program structure.
And we'll use that to generate
really compact output.
You could tell people what
happens if you use it.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: So currently,
when you use dash, dash,
minify, the only thing that
happens is that they are going
to old unnecessary wide spacing,
and the produced
methods is going
to be removed.
So it's nothing much, but in our
benchmarks we were able to
get down by 15%, maybe?
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: And that's
just by removing
all the wide spacing.
In future versions, yes, we want
to have a nice minifier,
and for us, it's definitely
easier than for a tool that
runs after on our
generated code.
So we will definitely have
something that will minify the
names and the properties and the
cast names and everything.
And when we do that, we
will provide that
mapping text file.
That shouldn't be difficult.
And there's no reason
not to do it.
SETH LADD: In fact, today
we're spitting out
a source map file.
We're not complete with
that feature yet.
But it is going to
be part of this
compilation and build step.
And it'll allow you to take
minified or unminified
JavaScript output, and through
the DevTools of Chrome, map it
back to the original
Dart code.
And it's a really cool
development workflow.
JJ BEHRENS: So this question
isn't about dart2js, but it
seems to be really popular.
"Is there a public roadmap as to
when we can expect Dart to
be ready for serious
deployment?
I'm thinking about trying out
larger projects and riskily
future proofing them
with Dart."
KASPER LUND: I don't think we
have a public roadmap for when
we're ready for that.
Right now, we're very much
focused on delivering this
first milestone release, where
we'll get all these new
language features implemented
across the board so you can
start relying on them
in the editor and
dart2js and on the VM.
So you can really start making
use of these new things.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, it's
definitely been my experience
that Dart is already a really,
really good tool for building
web stuff and is a really
productive tool.
But you have to understand
that you have to
move with the times.
We're not trying to be backwards
compatible ever
since last October.
We're always moving forward.
And as long as you're willing to
move forward with us, then
I think Dart's a really
productive tool.
SETH LADD: And I should
say that Dart is
an open source project.
You can follow along on
our mailing list.
You can follow along
on bug tracker.
We publish updates
from the team.
And so I would say certainly
give it a shot now.
And if there's something
specific you're looking for,
let us know on the
mailing list.
And if you're considering it
for a big project, we would
love to know what you're doing
and what your priorities are.
JJ BEHRENS: So "as a web
language, Dart needs to
interact with existing web
applications which use
JavaScript.
How does the dart2js compiler
enable interaction with legacy
JavaScript code like
jQuery?" This is
another popular question.
KASPER LUND: It's actually
a very good question.
So it's actually a very
difficult question.
Because whatever we do, we want
to make sure that you
have the same experience when
running dart2js and running on
the Dart VM so that code
you write today
will also run tomorrow.
So right now, the JavaScript
interrupt that we have is
fairly difficult to use.
We have some examples on how
you can build simple things
that interact with, for
instance, Google Maps and
things like that.
But it's somewhat painful.
And we're spending some time on
trying to figure out if we
can make it easier to use in a
way that still works both on
the Dartium, Dart VM-enabled
Chromium
builds, and on dart2js.
SETH LADD: So we should talk
about one of things that makes
this a really tough problem for
us, which is now that you
have multiple run times in the
browser, you run into what we
call a Distributed
GC situation.
JJ BEHRENS: Garbage Collection,
Distributed
Garbage Collection problems.
That's a challenge.
KASPER LUND: It's a big
challenge, right?
So you essentially have at least
three different memory
management systems
in the game.
You have the system that governs
all the DOM notes in
your web page.
You have the JavaScript memory
manager, and you have the Dart
memory manager.
And they need to coordinate
things.
And that may sound pretty easy,
but in reality, you want
the garbage collectors in those
systems to be really,
really efficient, incremental,
and give you essentially no
pause times and just
great throughput.
So combining that with a system
that tracks references
between them is just very,
very difficult.
So it's something that we're
trying to wrap our heads
around how to approach
and how to solve.
But it's certainly not an easy
task to get through that.
JJ BEHRENS: "Can the work on
type propagation improve the
code size and speed even
more in the future?
We still see pretty huge chunks
of bailout code and
type agnostic code generated,
which seems not necessary in
many cases/" So we kind
of touched on this.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: That's
an easy one.
That's yes.
Yes.
PETER VON DER AHE: We
have only scratched
the surface, I think.
KASPER LUND: Yeah.
So over the last month or two,
we've actually seen a lot of
progress there.
And I think this question refers
to the fact that it is
improving a lot, but we still in
certain cases see a lot of
things that could
get even better.
And that's nice for us because
that will keep
us busy for a while.
But it's certainly something
we focus a lot on, like
getting very good performance
out of the generated
JavaScript code through type
propagations, type
inferencing.
There's a lot of work going
on in that area.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: So the current
status is basically we
have been really very good
in local type inference.
So if there's a variable and
we know the type then we
propagate this type and use
it even for speculative
optimizations and things
like that.
And recently, we started to
use types on arguments and
return values and sometimes on
fields if they have been
initialized only in specific
occasions, or not too often,
and we can track it.
But there is work on a global
type inference tool that will
help to get much, much more
type information.
At the moment, we have
type information
produced by the code.
JJ BEHRENS: So "what features
of the Mirrors API do you
think will make it into dart2js
sooner than later?"
PETER VON DER AHE:
Introspection.
That's basically looking at the
program structure, but not
modifying it.
JJ BEHRENS: I've heard a lot of
people ask for this sort of
thing, because frameworks like
AngularJS rely on reflection
as a core feature of
how they work.
And so I know that a lot of
people were interested in
seeing reflection
in Dart as well.
PETER VON DER AHE: Yeah.
My take on that is that, yeah,
you can write a lot of
frameworks like that, and you're
probably gonna end up
feeling really clever when
you get it to work.
But it's probably also
frustrating when it's not
working for you because there's
a whole bunch of
things going on, right?
First you have--
well, in AngularJS, I don't
know if they have--
that's really a JavaScript
framework, right?
It's not a language.
So there's no compile
time step there.
But we already have a
compile time step.
So we should sort of take
advantage of that, and then
check your program there,
and then generate
some efficient code.
JJ BEHRENS: Check for
static warnings.
PETER VON DER AHE: Yeah, well,
we have a compile time step.
So we should take advantage
of that and use that.
But there's also--
for us to put in all the
information that is required
to do introspection or modifying
the program, then we
also have to follow those
convent-- so that when we
extend the program, the code we
have already generated has
to be compatible with
how it's extended.
So all of a sudden, reflection
can have an impact on how we
generate code.
So the first cut is prob--
that's why we have designed the
mirror system as it is.
It's basically--
it's a capability that
you request.
In this case, it would be
by importing a library.
If you import this library, that
may have to change how we
generate code.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: So just to
give some examples of what
changes would be needed.
If we mangled the feed name or
if we mangled the cast names,
well, then we would need to ship
some information to be
able to get back from
the mangled name to
the original name.
Similarly, if you are actually
allowed to change, if you add
a new codes to your reflection,
we cannot tree
shake anymore because you
might call a method that
wasn't called before.
KASPER LUND: A request for
feedback from anybody watching
this that's interested
in introspection.
And we love to get use case on
what kind of things you would
like to see there and which
parts of the introspection
APIs are you using.
And then we can start to think
about whether or not it's
realistic to get that rolled
into dart2js in the
not-too-distant future.
JJ BEHRENS: So "will it be
possible to write a new
library in Dart that could be
used either by Dart or plain
JavaScript?"
KASPER LUND: So it's certainly
something we
would like to see happen.
For us, we think that it's--
at least for certain things,
components you want to write,
it's more efficient to write
them in Dart than it is in
JavaScript.
So if we could allow you to do
that for certain components in
your big project and just use
them for other JavaScript
things, it would be
kind of neat.
It's something we're looking
at doing for the web
components work we're doing.
It would be very, very cool if
you could take a web component
that has behavior written
in Dart, compile it to
JavaScript, and use it
from any web page.
It's certainly something
we'd like to see.
So it's a great question, and
hopefully, we'll be able to
answer it with a, yes, let's
do it, very soon.
JJ BEHRENS: And then last one.
"If GWT can compile JavaScript
to run on Android browsers,
then why can't Dart?" I think
I've been hearing some
complaints that the JavaScript
doesn't work
on the Android browser.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: Committed
today.
JJ BEHRENS: Oh, committed.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: I just
committed a fix for the
obvious syntax problem.
I'm expecting to hear other bugs
that show me other maybe
different problems.
But it should work.
At least the syntax that was
really making it impossible to
run on Android processes
has been fixed.
KASPER LUND: And actually that's
another place where we
got a nice patch from an
external contributor.
That was kind of nice.
JJ BEHRENS: I would also say
if you could run Chrome for
your phone, it's a
nice experience.
FLORIAN LOITSCH: But to actually
answer the question,
why can GWT compile,
and why can't we?
Because they spent a huge amount
of resources doing it.
KASPER LUND: It's always a
matter of prioritization.
So it's great when we get
feedback from people that say
I would really use this if it
worked on Android browsers.
It's something we can use.
And we can think about whether
or not it makes sense to put
in the extra effort
to make it run.
JJ BEHRENS: When I compile my
Dart code to JavaScript using
dart2js, it doesn't really
work in Lynx,
my text-based browser.
KASPER LUND: I don't think
you've tried it.
It actually works just fine.
JJ BEHRENS: Does it, really?
KASPER LUND: No.
[LAUGHTER]
JJ BEHRENS: So thank you guys
for all your time today.
It's been a great show.
And I think we will see you
guys back when Seth and I
return to California.
And we'll do our next episode
in two weeks.
SETH LADD: Absolutely.
And thanks for watching
Dartisans.
You can find the Dart project
at dartlang.org.
Do join our mailing list at
dartlang.org/mailing-list.
And we have bug tracker
at dartbug.com.
Lots of good ways to get in
touch with us, and we're
always looking for feedback.
I mean, we certainly prioritize
things based on
what we hear.
We've taken external patches.
It's a really cool open
source project.
And so please do let us know
what you're using Dart for and
what you need it to do.
JJ BEHRENS: Goodbye from
[SPEAKING DANISH].
[ALL SPEAKING DANISH]
[MUSIC PLAYING]